let's get one thing out of the way water
fleas are not pleased for one fleas are
insects water fleas are a subset of
small crustaceans called clawed Asura
there are over 600 known species of
Clarins but scientists have estimated
that there might actually be around two
to four times that number water fleas
got their name because not only do they
you know kind of resemble fleas they've
also been known to jump like them and
it's kind of a strange experience to see
something that looks fairly familiar
reconfigured into the microcosmic if you
look at a Daphnia from the side you can
see the definite flea type shape that
informs their name but if you manage to
look at one from the top well I could
very easily lie to you and say that this
is a completely different organism and
you would probably believe me now of
course we would never do that that's not
the kind of show this is water fleas are
large in micro cosmos terms they range
from around 0.5 millimeters to 6
millimeters long absolutely gigantic and
they've got ten sets of appendages
distributed around their body including
two different sets of antennae one of
those is for sensing the other is for
swimming there's also an array of five
to six limbs that form a feeding and
respiratory apparatus as well as a pair
of claws at the end of their abdomen
which they use as a filtering tool or
for defense what might be especially
striking is that one very large eye
something we don't often see in the
micro cosmos as embryos closer ins have
to brown eye spots but in the last stage
of their development the eye spots
merged together to form one large
compound eye that will go on to help
orient them while they swim around
Ladouceur ins also have another small
photosensitive organ called the knobbler
eye which is located between the
compound eye and the mouth the water
fleas we see most in our journey through
the micro cosmos are Daphnia a genus
that includes more than a hundred
species and while yes Daphnia are found
in lakes they're also sold in aquarium
stores because fish love to eat them you
might see bags of them filled with
hundreds of Daphnia as they get packed
together the oxygen around them gets
depleted closer ins use hemoglobin to
transport oxygen and in situations like
this they can increase the concentration
of hemoglobin in their bodies up to
twenty fold to transport more oxygen and
as that happens you might actually see
those packs of Daphnia become a much
more vivid red
[Music]
here you can see the daphnia's heart
beating at twenty degrees Celsius it'll
be around two hundred times a minute but
that rate depends on the temperature it
beats slower when the Daphnia are in
colder conditions the heart rate will
also change in a presence of substances
like alcohol and caffeine but we are a
little bit too nervous about hurting our
Daphnia to demonstrate that our Daphnia
often come from those aquarium packs
rescued from their fate as fish food to
live a less hazardous life in our own
fish free pond aquarium they do
occasionally get eaten by the hydras in
the tank but it's a better chance of
survival compared with the alternative
Daphnia and they're closer and relatives
are filter feeders gathering their food
with a filtering apparatus made of their
limbs key among these are their philip
odds a set of flat legs that RISM
believes the philip odds create a water
current that flows from the front of the
water flee towards the back allowing it
to collect and consume algae here you
can see a Daphnia filtering a rotifer
all the rotifer is quickly discarded
probably because it's a bit too big for
easy consumption
while Daphnia are often transparent you
can sometimes get hints of just what
food is dominating their diet by looking
at the tinges of color that line their
body with more green algae the Daphnia
will start to look a little green or
yellow when they eat more bacteria you
might see more of a white or salmon pink
color Daphnia are of course often eaten
so they employ several strategies to
avoid predators including the tried and
true strategy of just getting the heck
out of the way only when Daphnia do it
we call it dial vertical migration
during the day when light is plentiful
they stick out lower darker depths where
predators are less able to see them
during the night they move upwards able
to eat without fear of looming threats
Daphnia arranged this dial vertical
migration around the presence of fish
Kyra moans Kyra moans are chemical
signals that alert them to the proximity
of fish if they don't detect these
signals the Daphnia might just spend the
day hanging out towards the surface so
they can gather more food but Kyra moans
don't just affect the daphnia's
migration they also affect the size of
their offspring in the presence of fish
Kyra moans one Daphnia species has been
observed birthing smaller water fleas a
change in size that helps them avoid
detection interestingly though the
presence of the Phantom midge another
predator sets off the opposite result
there Kyra moans will make the Daphnia
grow larger presumably because the midge
prefers a smaller prey in response to
the midges Kyra moans the Daphnia have
also been observed growing a set of
jagged edges on their head called neck
teeth you know all the usual protective
measures
growing extra-large and having teeth on
your neck environmental cues also shape
the reproduction of Daphnia by directly
affecting the sexual composition of
their population an adult female Daphnia
will usually go through a sexual
reproduction producing a clutch of
partha genetic eggs every time she
molt's the eggs go into her brood
chamber and after about a day they hatch
the young larvae stay inside her brood
chamber for about three more days
emerging as young Daphnia that are
genetically identical to their mother
with asexual reproduction a female
Daphnia might produce a clutch every
three to four days until her death
producing more clones of herself and
rapidly increasing their population
there are a few Daphnia species that are
strictly parthenogenetic but most follow
a pattern called cyclic parthenogenesis
interrupting their asexual cycle for
sexual reproduction this switch happens
in response to environmental cues
signaling that times have gotten tough
maybe the population has become too
dense and their food has become scarce
or perhaps the days are getting shorter
the temperature is lower or the pond
drier when these external danger signals
are sensed some of the partha
genetically derived eggs will start to
hatch into males these male Daphnia are
genetically identical to their female
brood mates after all they are part than
a genetically produced and that means
that sex and Daphnia is an
environmentally determined trait there
isn't a genetic difference between males
and females rather there's some kind of
external signal that takes a genetically
identical population of Daphnia and
determines whether some of them will
become male those males then reproduce
with females from other clutches
creating an opportunity for true gene
exchange following sexual reproduction
the female Daphnia will produce a
active saddle-like structure called
unofficial which holds two eggs called
the resting eggs when the female malts
she will shed the afib IAM two it might
sink to the bottom of the pond or
dispersed through the waterer with the
wind and where it lands it might rest
for years it's only when the environment
that surrounds the egg signals favorable
conditions that they will hatch
producing females that will soon proceed
back to their normal parthenogenetic
reproduction aschedule nature is full of
change light temperature your neighbors
these can alter dramatically over the
course of days weeks and years and so
the life of any organism from the
smallest microbe to the largest whale is
built on responding and adapting to the
changes around them compared to many of
their smaller neighbors water fleas
don't look like they would be the most
nimble in the face of existential threat
and our own footage they often stand out
like awkward giants straddling the thin
line that separates the world of the
micro and macro how could an organism
that doesn't quite seem to fit in either
world contend with the challenges of
both quite well apparently it's as if
they have managed to make the best of
both worlds mastering the reproductive
strategies of one while processing the
signals of the other yes it is true
water fleas may not be the most elegant
of the creatures we see in the micro
cosmos but with a bag full of ingenious
tricks
you can't deny but they've got style
thanks for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us if you like this well that
makes us really happy and if you want to
thank somebody you could thank us but
you can also thank all of the people on
this screen right now they are our
patrons on patreon they are the reason
we are able to make this fun show in
these uncertain times of constant change
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us we are at youtube.com
slash micro cosmos